[Music]
breaking news this Tuesday night a
landmark 40 billion dollar deal rejected
why ottawa's compensation agreement for
indigenous children harmed by the child
welfare system is in Jeopardy they
should pay for they legally owe
roadblocks to reconciliation I can't
accept this gift two police officers
failed to attend an apology ceremony
after wrong filet arresting an
indigenous man and his granddaughter
on their way home the Canadian women
released from an Isis detention camp in
Syria
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about a landmark
child welfare agreement that is now far
from a done deal it involves a 40
billion dollar Compensation Plan for
indigenous Children and Families when
the federal government announced it in
January it was called historic now the
Canadian Human Rights tribunal has
rejected it saying the deal leaves some
children and families out the agreement
set aside 20 billion dollars to
compensate young people harmed by
Canada's discriminatory child welfare
system and 20 billion dollars to reform
that system that tore indigenous
children from their communities for
decades our Heather urich's West is
following the developments Heather bring
us up to speed
Donna the Canadian Human Rights tribunal
has asked all parties to try again
rejecting this proposed settlement
because it doesn't do what Ottawa had
been ordered to do in previous rulings
which was to pay every indigenous child
and family harmed by Canada's on reserve
child welfare system a minimum of forty
thousand dollars in compensation this
element between Ottawa and the Assembly
of first nation was to be the largest in
Canadian history covering for children
and families on reserve or in the Yukon
who are discriminated against from 1991
on the compensation for each child or
family could have gone higher as well
depending on the severity of harms
experienced
when we looked at the small print we
realized that there's large numbers of
children who would go from forty
thousand dollars to zero and there are
others for whom their compensation would
be uncertain
so we didn't think that was right
because this is the victim's money it's
only theirs no one has a right to give
that away
there's disappointment this was a
Compensation Plan designed by First
Nations people for First Nations people
in a culturally specific way
my commitment to those Partners is that
we'll be with them in the for the Long
Haul to get to an agreement
Cindy Woodhouse the afn's Manitoba
Regional Chief is questioning whether
the human rights tribunal considered the
major implications of this decision
calling the rejection a decision so
devastating to so many people today and
for First Nations and Canadians who want
to have a better system this projection
means Ottawa is now heading back to
court continuing a legal battle with the
First Nations family and caring Society
over compensation that first started
back in 2007. Donna all right Heather
York's West in Calgary tonight thank you
there is deep disappointment in a
British Columbia indigenous Community
tonight two Vancouver Police Officers
did not show up at a traditional apology
ceremony they were invited to by the
helsink First Nation instead the event
became a way to honor Maxwell Johnson
and his granddaughter who were wrongly
accused of Fraud and arrested three
years ago while trying to open a bank
account two chairs were left empty in
the front row where the officers were
expected to be the apology ceremony was
part of a settlement agreement between
Johnson and The Vancouver Police board
Vancouver's police chief was there he
has denied there is systemic racism in
the force held's a hereditary Chief
Frank Brown questioned that
racism has been sheltered and condoned
if you don't hold individuals
accountable
nitu garcha is in the helsink nation
tonight nitu
Donna it was meant to be a night of
healing and moving forward but instead
it was referred to by the nation's
leadership as a missed opportunity to
start reconciliation
inside what helsink nation calls the big
house featuring art from the highly
respected man who was wrongfully
arrested along with his then 12 year old
granddaughter in 2019 are executive
members of The Vancouver Police
Department and the police board it's
been very traumatizing the last three
years but the arresting officers didn't
show up despite multiple invitations and
a disciplined decision against them
ordering them to apologize we're really
disheartened that the two constables
didn't arrive and come with you here
today the board does apologize for the
lasting pain and Trauma what was a
carefully planned apology ceremony
turned into an uplifting ceremony for
the family of Maxwell Johnson and
torianne we all stand in support with
you travel was not organized by the
nation nor was the flight passenger list
it's unclear why the officers didn't
attend but their absence fueled
frustration I can't accept this gift
the world is watching us
how Canada and how a city treats its
indigenous people is going to be a
powerful reflection
on what we profess to be a fair and just
Society The Vancouver Police Chief
didn't speak at the ceremony it was a
really thoughtful ceremony and I'm glad
that we were here but I'm not going to
be in the canyon statements tonight and
he tried to avoid any public comment
hereditary Chief Brown rejected the
apology and returned the gift what was
your reaction to that
no I accept it's a very emotional time
and it's a difficult thing for sure the
nation's leaders repeatedly emphasized
how their laws have been in place longer
than Canadian Colonial laws and they say
in order to have closure the arresting
officers need to come to the nation at a
future date
in a statement the police Union
confirmed the officers did not attend
for personal reasons and that they did
make an in-person apology after the
wrongful arrests were made nearly three
years ago heltic Nation maintains there
has never been a face-to-face apology as
required by the human rights settlement
Donna all right neethu Garcia and Bella
Bella BC thanks more evidence today in
the inquiry into the federal
government's use of the emergencies Act
and the so-called Freedom protests in
February in an email presented at The
Inquirer the RCMP commissioner suggested
not all policing options had been
exhausted before the Act was invoked and
as our chief political correspondent
David Aiken reports the commission has
also been given intelligence reports
showing police were worried about
attacks on Parliament Hill and that
foreign actors were leveraging the
Convoy for their own gain
hours before prime minister Justin
Trudeau invoked the emergencies act last
February RCMP commissioner Brenda lucky
emailed a top Trudeau government
political Aid saying I am of the view
that we have not yet exhausted all
available tools that are already
available through the existing
legislation obviously that's what we
thought so this is why we are not in
supportive of that special law to
address this specific issue lucky did
not specify what those available tools
might have been but she did list some
potentially useful new powers she
thought would be available under the
emergencies act such as jamming cell
phones and arresting people for
supplying the protesters with fuel that
lucky email is part of the evidence
table that the commission reviewing the
decision to invoke the emergencies act
on Tuesday an Ottawa police officer
testified that police at the time were
concerned the Convoy protest might take
a cue from those who attacked the
American Capital on January the 6th 2021
there was a lot of references that were
popping up in social media saying this
was going to be their January 6th and
this was the I believe this was the same
day that we started reaching out to uh
have other public order units from other
police services to be in town to support
us and one of the documents now before
the commission is a February 19th
intelligence report from the Ontario
Provincial Police that indicates that
police were worried that quote foreign
adversaries may be using the Convoy to
further their own strategic economic and
political interests if so their
activities may represent an ongoing
threat to National Security and even
though that warning about a national
security threat from foreign adversaries
was in a police intelligence report
published four days after the
emergencies Act was invoked it will
almost certainly be cited by the Trudeau
government as one of the factors that
led it to make that emergency
declaration Donna okay David Aiken on
that inquiry in honor thanks to Canadian
women and two children who have been in
a camp for Isis detainees in Syria for
more than three years are believed to be
returning to Canada tonight sources say
one of the women is British Columbia
native Kimberly Pullman who Global News
spoke to at the camp in 2019. our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson is
following this developing story for us
Mercedes
well Donna this is a remarkable first
tonight it's the first time the Canadian
government has actually intervened to
bring an Isis bride home before they had
said if people were able to get back to
the Border they had a right to re-enter
the country and they would perhaps under
certain circumstances help to provide
documentation but Global News can report
tonight that this was actually
facilitated by Foreign Affairs and the
government of Canada with the help of
U.S assets and that was to extract
Kimberly Pullman a BC woman who had been
in a detention camp in Northeast Syria
for three years to come home she was
believed to be seriously ill in fact
before she even left Canada she was put
on permanent disability at the
recommendation of a psychiatrist along
with her is another Canadian woman from
Quebec and her two children Pullman
qualified for something called
extraordinary assistance and it's
described in a letter that we have
obtained from the federal court it talks
about how ill she is and that is one of
the exemptions the government of Canada
will make to Bringing Home someone who
left Canada to participate in Isis or in
this case of these two women to marry
someone from Isis it does not look that
this is necessarily a new stage for the
Canadian government but there's lots of
questions about that we asked Marco
Mendicino about it today he's the
minister of Public Safety here's what he
had to say
supporting a terrorist group whether
here or abroad is a serious criminal
offense and those who engage in that
kind of activity will face the full
force of the law and with regards to the
types of cases that you're talking about
of course our number one concern will
always be the Safety and Security
Canadians
the Canadian government has been
reluctant to bring the more than one
dozen Canadians home from detention
camps in Syria owing to concerns about
whether or not they can charge them
under Canadian law it's unclear whether
Kimberly Pullman and the other woman
with her will face those charges when
they return to Canada which is expected
to be tonight Donna or to come on that
story Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank
you the merger between Shaw and Rogers
ran into a big snag today the federal
government has set out new conditions
for Roger's proposed takeover of its
rival Shaw Communications blocking a
side deal on transferring Wireless
assets unless it guarantees better
prices for Canadians the proposed 26
billion dollar merger was already Under
Fire over concerns it could mean
Canadians would have less choice and
could face higher prices for their cable
Internet and mobile services industry
Minister Francois Philippe champagne
formerly rejected the transfer of the
wireless Spectrum today but did leave
the door open to a revised deal Rogers
had been aiming to complete its takeover
of Shaw by the end of this year
promises from Britain's third Tory prime
minister this year
coming up what Rishi sunac is going to
do differently
there is a new conservative leader in
charge of the UK Rishi sunak today
officially became Britain's third prime
minister in two months after the brief
chaotic tenure of Liz truss but what is
he going to do differently in a country
where inflation is over 10 percent and
the economy is teetering I will place
economic stability and confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come
AC promises to restore trust and rebuild
confidence voters though have heard that
before as Eric Sorensen reports he must
dig his party and his country out of a
deep hole
first the formalities for Britain's
shortest tenured prime minister in
history thank Liz trust Bid Farewell
then offered her resignation at
Buckingham Palace and soon after Rishi
sunak arrived invited by King Charles to
form the UK's next government for the
fifth conservative prime minister in six
years it was important to project
stability within his party and for a
country deeply in debt and grappling
with 10 percent inflation right now
our country is facing a profound
economic crisis
many are watching Jeremy Hunt the
minister for finance faces tough
decisions whether to increase taxes and
cut spending the British pound
strengthened today which is a good start
for sunac he needs to build confidence
he's got a hell of an agenda required to
fix the problems of the UK
sunac exudes confidence he broke through
an ethnocultural ceiling to be the first
British Asian prime minister he had the
benefit of private schools as a Young
Man a background in finance and married
into one of India's wealthiest families
now the youngest prime minister since
1812 has Bridges to mend after Boris
Johnson and Liz truss I have work to do
to restore Trust after all that has
happened that trust will not come
overnight I think it's the best of a bad
bunch in every circumstance prime
minister Trudeau issued a statement
extending congratulations to sunac
calling Canada's partnership with the UK
one of the strongest relationships
between any two countries in the world
for Ottawa those relationships with
sunax Inner Circle matter starting with
the Prime Minister himself the
chancellor responsible for finance the
foreign secretary the UK defense
secretary and at International Trade
kemi badnock
badnock will be part of Britain's team
negotiating a new free trade deal with
this country Canada has a lot at stake
in getting a good British government and
I think that sunac has the potential to
provide that what the new prime minister
hopes won't be needed now for a long
time is the moving van spotted today
behind 10 Downing Street Eric Sorensen
Global News
bad news today for American basketball
star Brittany Greiner a Russian court
has upheld a nine-year prison sentence
for drug possession the eight-time
American WNBA All-Star was convicted in
August after Customs officials at Moscow
airport found Vape canisters containing
less than a gram of cannabis oil in her
luggage see she said she packed it
inadvertently and pleaded guilty Greiner
could be moved to one of Russia's
notorious penal colonies unless the U.S
government is able to negotiate a deal
for her release
backlash against the Bank of Canada it
had political pressure on the eve of
another interest rate hike
[Music]
the Bank of Canada is expected to
announce another Hefty interest rate
hike tomorrow in its continued push to
bring down soaring inflation across the
country after being at an historic low
of 0.25 percent for nearly two years the
key lending rate has been hiked five
times since March and is now at 3.25
percent the Bank of Canada Governor has
signaled more hikes are coming tomorrow
it could rise to four percent and that
would push borrowing costs to the
highest they've been since 2008. it is a
rapid Spike some economists and now
politicians are questioning and geviola
explains
the Royal Bank says that the average
family will pay three thousand dollars
more in inflation and higher interest
rates attacks on the Bank of Canada now
coming from across the political
Spectrum those increases are going to
mean people are going to hurt
and and put bluntly it's going to mean a
very likely recession where hundreds of
thousands of Canadians are going to lose
their jobs this month in an exclusive
interview with global news Central Bank
Governor Tiff macklam explained the need
to raise rates by making borrowing more
expensive people are going to borrow
less spend less and save more and that's
going to take some of the steam out of
inflation jugmeet Singh says our Central
Bank should become like the Federal
Reserve in the U.S which has a dual
mandate to tame inflation and promote
maximum employment but the national
jobless rate is already lower than most
have seen in a lifetime we're looking at
Labor shortages that we haven't seen in
half a century and they are very broad
spread across every type of skill type
every type of region this former
political science Professor warns
against the Central Bank bowing or being
seen as caving to political pressure If
you undermine the Bank of Canada
uh what will happen is that you may have
the kind of financial crisis that
Britain was just thrown into that's
because investors tend to trust the
Central Bank more than elected officials
the institution is independent tasked
with maintaining price stability
otherwise it risks losing investor
confidence in our bonds stock market and
currency so it'll probably lead to
dramatic decline in the value of the
Canadian dollar and if you think that
that's going to help fight inflation
you're wrong how high they go for how
long is going to depend on the evolution
of the economy and importantly the
evolution of inflation rate hikes
typically take up to two years to be
fully felt throughout the economy but
already our Central Bank is one of the
most aggressive in the fight against
inflation and gaviola Global News
Toronto